we've got a busy night ahead of us we're
sharing the ceremony in full here on Sky
News and on Sky showcase a little later
on but look this is the the Calm before
the storm it is a military operation
getting everyone inside in their seats
it's a three and a half hour carpet
event that is involves people being
given certain time slots you don't want
to have a backlog of celebrities uh
waiting for for photographs they all
know when they're meant to come along
you've already missed Brendan Fraser
who's nominated for the best actor
um who else have we've had about the
director of All Quiet on the Western
Front the film really that everyone is
talking about though going into tonight
is of course everything everywhere all
at once Michelle yeoh is up for best
actress Jamie Lee Curtis is up for best
supporting
um and really Jamie Curtis we brought up
with her a few times this award season
she's absolutely
most of the time she's having the time
of her life picking up all of these
Award nominations winning the last one
at the SAG Awards is tipped to do very
well tonight will she come away with the
best supporting award she told me that
she didn't want to sort of go that far
she was just enjoying the evening and
here's what she said about the film
itself
it is a movie about love and
reunification between a mother and a
daughter and a husband and a wife
and it's yeah it has sausage fingers and
it has sausage fingers when you are
reading a script and you look down and
it says put your sausage fingers on
what can I say you just have to trust
the vision I suppose totally trust a
vision yes
no there are there aren't many films
that also deliver on the perfect
Halloween costumes going forward I think
a lot of people will be donning sausage
fingers come Halloween this year it's a
brilliant brilliant watch will it come
away with the most Awards tonight we'll
we'll find out a bit later on will it
win the big one best picture or could we
see an upset don't forget you've got
these big Blockbusters like Top Gun
nominated as well a big fan favorite
we'll find out later